while significant progress has been made
to strengthen the financial system I
believe the Act did not go far enough I
believe the biggest banks are still too
big to fail and continue to pose an
ongoing large risk to our economy
failures of large financial institutions
pose massively asymmetric risk to
society that policymakers must consider
we had a choice in 2008 spend taxpayer
money to stabilize large banks or don't
and potentially trigger many trillions
of addition of additional cost to
society a very crude analogy is that of
a nuclear reactor the cost to society of
letting a reactor meltdown is
astronomical given that costs
governments will do whatever they can to
stabilize the reactor before they lose
control I believe we need to complete
the important work that my colleagues
are doing so that at a minimum we are as
prepared as we can be to deal with an
individual large bank failure but given
the enormous cost that would be
associated with another financial crisis
and the lack of certainty about whether
these new tools would be effective in
dealing with one I believe we must
seriously consider bolder
transformational options breaking up the
large banks into smaller less connected
less important entities turning large
banks into public utilities by forcing
them to hold so much capital they
virtually can't fail with regulation
akin to that of a nuclear power plan
taxing leverage throughout the financial
system to reduce systemic risks wherever
they lie the financial sector has
lobbied hard to preserve its current
structure and thrown up endless
objections to fundamental change and in
the immediate aftermath of the financial
crisis when the dodd-frank act was first
passed the economic outlook was perhaps
too uncertain to take truly bold action
but the economy is stronger now and the
time has come to move past parochial
interests and solve this problem the
risks of not doing so are simply too
great